Lydia he's Lydia where you from her joy
where'd you grow up
Santa Barbra and tell me about your
family you grew up with both your
parents no just my mom just your mom
where was dad no no need to go you never
knew yeah and how was your childhood
hard what was the hard part about being
raised were there problems if your mom
or yeah she's an alcoholic
your mom's alcoholic yeah yeah what cup
what kind of stuff going on when you're
a kid another case that it means abuse
me to maintain you physically from your
mom yeah my sister's yeah
my mom on my holiday
[Music]
she added my dad and my dad and he
wanted to do it her so I'm the rejected
family youngest yeah but what made you
feel like you weren't wanted she told me
that would do it with a dream when you
left home
15:15 how bad did the with you scared
when you woke up what kind of stuff
happen you made my family move out here
with your mom with your family well she
tried to come on I have a few times you
know she she tried to what did mean I
take your life yeah
how would she do that she put a knife to
me way back when I was a teenager and I
was a baby she trying to drown me and um
when I was a young adult do metal car
Goodridge I don't what just a man on the
corner she push me other client pushed
you out of the car did she disappear yet
sisters and brothers no they're the
pedestals they were high up there I was
in here how is everyone
did you treat that the same way that you
treat you hmm so you left home with 15
where did you go the streets
my family's here I don't like it
I feel like a ding yeah you're joining
gang no nobody's just people on the
street that became your good family
yeah but most of you moms got my cell
below being out here is hard um a lot of
testimonies you know three years ago I
was kidnapped I think I was tortured out
here pretty bad they got ahold of me
there was two girls and two guys they
spread me apart they beat me to my tea
so they burned me he took my hair broke
my ribs my face take my soul take my
spirit you know I'm not racist but I'm
scared of black people
the night with me one of the Hubble's
people out here for you everybody but um
discover myself you try to get into
how's nature and get myself together
are you using any drugs marijuana
what's it I smoke marijuana I used to do
heroin between ten years did you play
off heroin protect the streets I keep
close turkey and John Jr at the drop-in
center is it very good yeah
cold turkey and I'm about you you you're
one of the kids been able to say you
know um being here 28 years by the grace
of God I said I my sanity you know and
his face still seems to shock me you
know it's thinking's me that stand-ins
me but he's a happening now trying to
give her his way around you know how
many years living in here was good right
28 years 28 years 20:52
you have kids I have two boys did you
did you raise them yeah so what um being
out here I've heard things I don't want
to hear I've seen things that I didn't
want to see these are happy Harry then I
wish I were saving me
but I'm okay you know Wow
but a month ago I was kept by her Clark
there's no purchase but actually I was
information is to give me a body here
you know I don't ask for too much
narrowness between little just what's
fair you know see Mike how many getting
to know you still talk to your kids
they're mad at me and you do their kind
of stirring hard tougher now keeping
container menu for what reason now did
you if you're cleaning off heroin
because I'm out here but they don't open
the door you made me do to me either
you know I want to bother you
I just heard I care you know there's
there were more dangerous now
everybody's dying out here you've been
here 28 years what kind of stuff have
you seen whatever it reaps little
murders maybe beating up on living men
reaping mean animals being abused people
there any [ __ ] even crap
people are spice
I believe she's like that so here four
friends dance my
so what what you still live here here
you're not doing heroin I don't pity
society this lady's hard keep her cool
you know I should be used to the in Kali
but I'm not it still hurts you know
people look at me like I'm not sturdy
here they don't do that do you think the
way that you were raised the way your
mom treated you is as a park playing you
know yeah your self perception is my
self esteems yeah it's just so low that
you do you think this is where you
belong
thank you
[Music]
what are you doing for money now recycle
recycle kids never bridge
Oh
I'll hook somebody's Tanika rap you know
hook it up for them in Octavian
in the past have you done other things
like title still little prostitute I
don't take for people tasty little
longer me take my finger is you know I'd
be mistaken for somebody somebody else
they tried to set us neatly they wanted
to kill me because I was thought of
somebody else
a few times when the truth finally came
up a living an apology it would take for
me can I can
it's hard you know people think is
decided if you feel if you open as it's
not you know I think I got a red sheet
there my right my laundry
my dating mahadji's my radio my
batteries my lights my pair of shoes
Billy you know got it here all right I
want a puppy look at me so bad it hurts
you don't eat the only animals out here
being abused
for fighting it's so wrong you know I
just talked to a couple people from
abusing their hand I'm gonna have the
guitar imagine
I'd be doing
first off your army
how about repurposing all the great
Hey
[Music]
cool
because I have only asked for it
I try to get my house they have a trap
at two years something I was percent
wrong the kind of a relationship you
can't have a relationship body here but
I'm lonely too
it's hard
how'd everyone stay scared to do it my
shoes on
cats get it right
see poacher not you in a heartbeat
have no friends
keep I know that about myself but I do
take advantage of me
be nicer give this letter here are
versatile to try somebody's hard
looking back at your life what do you
what do you wish that played out
differently it might have changed your
peace of mind still here comfortably it
would be snappy
stay peaceful demonstrators who worries
just peace you feel like your childhood
is so traumatic that it just kind of set
you back and kept you that way and now
you're here you don't feel like you're
capable of getting out I'm trying
he said he'd always kiss me back I said
I was hit by a car getting through that
I wish she had thought I accent my bike
and they snip my cribs they tell me is
just what accent medicals tell me relax
a good moon
[Music]
don't have time for me I don't get a
penny recycler to me
but I might anxious to scream with you
steal my things
just nap here you know I don't mess of
people now do you sign in you even go
stay here the rest of your life so I
don't know it's been down here for
almost three decades I know
[Music]
that's it out of here people like you
were dying I hear you old overdosing or
are to be or a killing or something it
scare me
okay you been caught out into the street
not rights no I was scared
the only thing I wanted was my ball is
your mom still right yeah
you talk to her no she don't think you
do Tricia's just do it first hit me you
hit me makes me feel better so you plug
your mom just like your kids no I mean I
talk to my sister my sister's tell the
boys hi you know I'm never gonna miss
them you don't talk to me
they understand one out of the way they
don't understand why I stay away
then you're not always with the two you
know
on a previous cuter
just don't stop letting me talk I'm
suicidal
about
my boys have only tried hanging myself I
throw put it and everybody outside
okay I get down sketchy we just watch by
cars just roll by something we just
nothing left
I'm gonna become a gene go away get out
of here but I'm not only this I don't
they're happy to me and I like somebody
I don't meet joke right
I got talks to me nicely right away did
you want something or get hit me
attached to them to what for what except
being you'll be again stealing from me
I heard people talk behind my back
you know I've heard office miss coffee
names
if my mother sees her back anyone
imagine a stranger
and the people that kill that video
still out there and they believe me they
gave me now
what do you think is stopping you from
just getting out of Skid Row changing
your life getting job didn't my
appearance
you're like my appearance what's wrong
with your piss look at me I'm sex you
get my skin
you're beautiful what's the matter
[Music]
he's gonna call me pizza
I was told I was angry
[Music]
you think that maybe your
self-perception might be these problems
you have anyway your self-perception
might be the biggest problem if you have
misperception the way you see yourself
because I look at you I see you're
beautiful I see nothing wrong with you
just being young he's my expiry tell me
I would like me it's like boyfriend and
he's disabled I was thinking here here
for two years
he's combining a wheelchair for what the
time to do that thank you
you took advantage of me who's always a
diaper let me see him disrespect me I'll
be names
I thought it's important you know
I'm gonna be grateful I never did
like the drugs when I first did my I was
witty crack 24 years old
I like the hell it was but my sister got
me a bottle of dick tasty you like you
27 years leaders taking me now talking
about wonder a legit did Allen DeGeneres
it's a she she'd OD somebody give me
laser and laser treatment with my finger
I want to be beautiful but have free
skin you know I never gave everyone a
foot makeup on my face or be scared
about my kid people are being
all right Lydia well thank you so much
for talking it good luck with everything
thank you
you